celebrations on the streets of the
kyrgyz capital bishkek
after the president suramay jim beckhoff
resigned
it comes after more than two weeks of
chaos in a country
that has seen two other presidents
forced out in revolutions
in the last 15 years
[Applause]
unjust people were ruling the country we
got rid of them
inshallah now everything will be fine we
are happy
we want hooray ginbekov and
pro-government parties are widely
accused of rigging the october the
fourth
parliamentary elections the central
election committee
annulled the results and has called for
a rerun of the poll
but the man seen as finally forcing the
president's resignation
the new prime minister sander japarov is
considered by many
as a threat to what little remains of
this country's
fledgling democracy japaroff had been
serving an 11-year jail term for
kidnapping
before he was freed by supporters during
the recent
post-election protests
his supporters now want parliament to be
dissolved
[Music]
thank god people are happy now we're
calling for 120 lawmakers to make a
statement
for there to be a self-dissolution of
parliament because people don't want
them here they want siddhi yaparov to
take power and start working
because they only support him
just hours after president gene beckhoff
resigned the parliamentary speaker
who along with prime minister japan was
voted into office in recent days
refused to take up his role as acting
president
the refusal of the parliamentary speaker
to be interim president gives acting
presidential power to the new prime
minister
sadira japarov a man whom many in this
country
deeply oppose the political crisis and
uncertainty in kyrgyzstan
is not over yet charles stratford al
jazeera bishkek